foreign
Chicago what's up Tina
hey John how we doing glad to be talking
to you today I'm glad to be talking to
you what's up I could I could really use
your advice maybe maybe
so for the last uh six months or so I've
been living in this in between place in
my marriage where I'm half in half out I
feel stuck unable to move forward and
it's taking a big toll on me so my
question for you today is it possible to
fall back in love with your spouse
I can give you some background
off the top of my head I'm going to say
no I think you should move out
okay now I just said that to be
provocative when I said that you kind of
smiled and laughed
how did you feel when I said that
I figured you were joking oh okay well
there we go I'm not very good at this
job so normally when somebody tells me
they're stuck
I will do my best to convince them right
off the bat that one answer is the right
one
because usually it's like setting a
puzzle piece in and you know if it fits
or not and so
um or you will push back and immediately
start to fight me like no I'm in this
Mir right so it becomes something very
powerful
um why
why have you and I'm I'm intentionally
using these words why are you choosing
to be stuck
that's a good question maybe if I give
my background it might help just
Enlighten to what's going on so
we've been married for almost five years
together for seven we have two kids a
stepchild and one together
shortly after we got married I realized
how much anxiety and alcohol consumed my
husband
when I was pregnant and after our son
was born it got worse and I became the
default parent it's been really hard
after many failed attempts to get his
addiction under control I hit my
breaking point last fall but I wasn't
really ready to move out and I gave
myself until the end of the year
in November I finally told him that I
would not keep living like this and he
said he heard me differently than all of
the other times before and he's been
showing consistent real change for the
past four to five weeks
so for so long I visualized My Life as a
single parent without him because I
didn't see him changing and making some
of the strides that he has been more
recently I just know that it feels like
I don't have the same feelings as he
does for me anymore and I feel stuck in
deciding like can I jump back into this
or is it time to
move on kind of without him yeah I mean
you left him
you left him a while ago
and
you waited for a while to tell him and
you told him in the form of a
if-then statement if you don't do this
then I'm gonna fill in the blank
and he called your bluff
and now you're in a mess right
it feels like the more honest thing
would have been just in November
actually back in June back in
uh March
to say I can't be in a marriage I I feel
unsafe
because you are an alcoholic I feel
unsafe because you're not taking care of
yourself
um I'm out
that would that would have been the most
honest way or to say I am considering
leaving you because I don't feel safe
and that's not happen though so here we
are so it sounds to me like you left now
you chose to
withdrawal
and so I think one million percent you
can choose to hop back in
he's at the very very very beginning
stages of sobriety
and when somebody tells me someone
struggling with alcohol and anxiety
that's I I immediately go to
a connection issue relationship issues
probably stemming from a long long time
ago
and you tell me they escalate
uh when you had a kid
especially first kid is when most
couples report an a
significant reduction in
connectivity intimacy and of course you
have another human that suddenly
figuring out how to take care of right
and so that is a that isn't that isn't
surprise me at all that he got more
anxious because his body felt more
disconnected alone and he drank more to
shut up the anxiety alarms like that
doesn't that it bothers me it's not a
great uh response but it makes perfect
sense
and so the question you have to ask
yourself is are
you willing to
quit being in the middle here go all in
on this marriage
ask him how can I help meet your needs
and you probably for the first time
commit to being honest on a regular
ongoing basis about what you need
if you're willing to do that man I think
you can get there if you have left the
relationship though don't be cruel to
him don't be cruel to yourself don't be
cruel to your kids
um
make your adult decision and then live
with the adult consequences and move on
about your day
it's been hard because like I said the
field attends it'll be okay for a while
and he'll try really hard and I'll
believe okay this time is different and
so I do I have like re-engaged come back
in and then inevitably it goes off the
rails again and it's just kind of that
consistent and I just feel like it's
kind of beat into me that
you know it's a pattern and so it's also
hard to figure out you know is this
consistent change that seems very real
to me he says it feels different
more recently is like how do I move past
you know some of the fears that I have
that this is just another like failed
attempt and that's really kind of where
I care a lot less about feelings right
now
I don't care how he feels
I care what he's doing
and
you need to feel your body's trying to
get your attention saying hey we've been
down this road we hurt every time your
body's doing exactly what it's supposed
to be doing you just have to decide I
hear you I hear you and this has gotten
us hurt before
but I'm going to choose to be vulnerable
and go all in one more time
or
you're right it's time for us to get out
of here
because you the one thing I know for
certain is your relationship will end if
you've got one foot in and one foot out
and it will end catastrophically or in a
huge mess and you end up in a weird way
becoming the bad guy
right
and so I would tell you to be a be a
person of integrity and I don't mean
that in a like to be throwing grenades
at you but be in or be out and if you're
in
say every time this gets me hurt every
time this drags me through the mud
um you hurt me you drag me through the
mud
and I'm choosing to go all in again and
here's what this is going to look like
have you outlined not what he needs to
be doing but have you outlined what you
need to be whole in this marriage
yes we've had a conversation multiple
times I mean more recently was probably
a couple months ago but when I did tell
him that I wouldn't keep living like
this like he referenced like some of the
things that I had shared before so he
knows what they are okay what is he
doing to get sober
and stay sober
so he weekly has been working with a
counselor that specializes in addiction
and is helping like through his anxiety
and past traumas and things like that
we've been going
um it's been sporadic but we go to the
same counselor that he sees individually
together
um but more specifically like things
that he's been doing like he has not
been putting himself in Temptation uh
meaning like going to the bars
unless it's for a specific thing or he
has specific kind of goals in mind top
of mind he
he's catching himself a lot more instead
of like reacting in a normal way he's
taking the time to like really think
about it be conscious
um so I see that he's doing like the
internal work in addition to like I said
working with his counselor so you
mentioned a bun and those are five
things the fine things especially
getting professional help
um in a perfect world he'd be going to a
group three or four times a week
especially here at the beginning
um but I'll leave that between him and
his counselor
um
you named a bunch of things that he is
stopping doing
he's stopping being reactive he's
stopping going to the bars he's stopping
filling the blank that's all fine and
good
the only way I believe this is
sustainable is if you two decide some
things you're going to do together that
you are that are going to replace some
of those things he doesn't go to the bar
you all have a weekly night that y'all
put the kids to bed and you both stay up
30 minutes later and you just hang out
you play questions for humans you are
silly y'all make out like you used to
when you were dating like whatever
things you play dominoes I don't care
what you're doing you watch now I would
rather you not watch a show together
because that can just be numbing too but
watch the show together if that's what
you got to do so I would love we're
gonna go for walks together we're gonna
go to the gym together we are going to
have one couple or one group of friends
over to our house every week we're gonna
make ourselves do it even when the house
is a wreck and we're tired we're gonna
figure this out because we're going to
start not only stop doing things that
hurt us but we're going to start adding
things
doing things participating in a way of
life that makes the whole environment
less anxious
and that's connectivity that's free
we're going to pay our debts off we're
going to find those things that make us
anxious
we're going to get rid of a bunch of
clutter and a bunch of crap you see what
I'm saying so we're gonna we're gonna do
positive things too and that's where you
can not just sit on the sidelines with
your arms folded judging him to see if
he's making progress
but this is where you are vulnerable and
you participate in what happens next
you become you'll you'll begin to
you're building a new life together a
non-anxious life together so
to answer your original question do I
think you can fall back in love
absolutely I do
um
do I will I ever know the ins and outs
of the abuse you've experienced and no I
don't and so only you can make that call
um
just because I think you can doesn't
mean it's gonna happen is it maybe a
better way to phrase it is is it
possible yes likely I I don't know
what I do know is if you're gonna stay
in it you gotta be all in and being all
in means you got to be vulnerable and be
invulnerable means you might get hurt
again
it's the only way love works
I hate it I don't like the design I wish
I could be kind of in and kind of you
can't
and on the other side if you're going to
be I'll be all the way out don't torture
him don't torture you don't drag those
kids through it if you're out be out
and as long as you're in
um this relationship moving forward
never wait one month five months nine
months to communicate
your needs
love yourself enough to be heard on a
daily basis on a weekly basis because
your needs matter
let me know what you decide I'm
interested to see where this thing heads
and I'll be here if you need anything
further